hello and welcome to new rockstars mr.
Powell salmon we got a wee bit of good
news going into the end of the year we
finally got a release date for the solo
black at a movie starring Dwayne if he
can smell what The Rock is cookin
Johnson
The Rock posted this image to Instagram
created by DC artist icon Jim Lee and my
personal favorite Pro fan artist
boss logic of a hyper realistic
depiction of the rock as the classic
Shazam villain as well as a release date
that is not too far off December 22nd
2021 pretty friend that Shazam was set
during Xmas time and now the spin-off is
coming out around the same time and
we're getting not one not two not five
but we're getting three DC movies coming
out in 2021 the Batman The Suicide Squad
and the Black Adam know then the title
as of yet but it would be a nice fit
right as of right now the rock is
attached to play Black Adam along with
jungle cruise director yo Mako let's era
who will be directing as well rampage
writer Adam cycle has been tapped to
write the script but besides that we've
got no more info on the film but now
that we got our calendars mark let's
answer the big questions who is Black
Adam and what makes this movie different
from jizz Sam and the other DC
properties well first off like Adam
effing rules does my professional
opinion honestly he probably would be
the perfect fit in a Zack Snyder
universe for the DC properties but
that's just not gonna happen I mean the
dude kills people willy-nilly all the
time Zack Snyder written all over it now
for the history nerds black Adams first
appeared in the Marvel family number one
in December 1945 yeah the students been
around for a minute after DC acquired
the rights to the Captain Marvel catalog
of characters black Adam was reduced
into the mainstream continuity and a
sword to a fan favorite villain slash
antihero Black Adam has all the same
powers of Suzanne but his abilities are
bestowed upon him by the Egyptian
Pantheon and not the Greek we got Chu
Hirsch if I'm on duty
I'm poo and meant to Shazam basically
fight super strength speed lightning
blast and can transform between a mortal
and the protector of magic with a simple
made-up magic word Shazam he's even got
a similar costume to Billy Batson aka
Captain Marvel a kay Shazam a K whatever
name they end up calling him in the next
movie big lightning ball on the chest
he's got the arm gauntlets golden boots
for a golden God and the famous cape
slash hood combo now this is where our
character similarities and and they
become two very distinct individuals
Black Adam famously dons a black version
of the costume and he's been at this
super-powered game quite a bit long
Billee try roughly 3,000 years longer
originally black Adam popped up in Egypt
around 12 79 BC and DC has since chains
Adams homeland to a fictional nation
conduct now there been a few iterations
of black Adams origin but to sum them up
each mention that Adam receives the
power from the wizard Shazam just like
in the film he uses these powers to
protect his homeland either Egypt or
conduct and is usually corrupted by said
powers and has them stripped by the
wizard or is imprisoned for all eternity
for his crimes now most recently in the
new 52 reboot of Shazam we learned that
Adam was not the one who received the
powers from the wizard much like how
Billy gave his powers to his siblings
Adam received his powers from his nephew
Amon who might have possibly been killed
by Adam by the way way back in ancient
conduct honestly it seems pretty clear
to me when I read the comic that Adam
killed his nephew but I've read online
that some people keep it ambiguous and
honestly if we want to like the rock in
the movie maybe keep that ambiguous or
ditch it all together anyone's call
really up to you guys I can't see the
rock being a total murderer in over this
movie as for why he would make his way
to present day well we've got two cool
options one he's found in a tomb like in
the new 52 sort of like a mummy or
option number two the wizard banishes
him into the deepest darkest depths of
the cosmos and he has to fly back to
earth and it takes thousands of years
cool either or I dig both of them now
usually he becomes the leader of the
fictional Middle Eastern country of
conduct in both the past and eventually
in the present as well this is where we
could get a different feeling from other
DC properties we're going to see someone
gain immense power without having the
purest heart and become corrupted by it
now nothing that's not happened in a
superhero movie before but this is our
protagonist we're talking about not some
bumbling maniacal villain I think we'll
see a story that spans millennia of a
man who fights for what he believes in
and stands up for those who have no one
to help them that being said he is going
to have to sort of become the villain by
the end of the story right I mean even
when he's the good guy in the comic we
still see him flying through dudes like
they're made of some sort of jello but
back to the comics for just a second
thanks to writers like Geoff Johns and
David s Goyer Black Adam has evolved
from a one-note body for Shazam to one
of the most morally complicated villains
we love in Justice Society of America oh
that comic is here we see Black Adam
attempting to redeem himself after if
you had this murderous
what persona Theo Adam removed from his
psyche I didn't mention that before
because basically all DC Comics has
chosen to forget that but worth
mentioning now with that in mind let's
talk about what could happen in this
movie and other DC characters we could
see showing up there have been rumors at
the Justice Society of America or JSA
could be making an appearance in this
film or possibly just a few members from
the team the Justice Society of course
is the precursor to the Justice League
during the 1930s and 40s these
characters do exist in present day but
like I said we could see the ROC's
character moving through the centuries
trying to protect his people and be
beaten back by others like the wizard or
outside forces now my guess for who
these outside forces could be who's
another DC character that's been around
basically all of human history that's
right say it with me Vandal Savage
a caveman who has bestowed
hyper-intelligent super strength and
immortality savages constantly
attempting to bring order to the world
or just conquering it altogether you
know there's kind of hodgepodge him
altogether
what better threat for black Adam
someone whose main goal is to protect
his people than a man who wants to unify
the world under one rule and is a being
that could take a full brunt of his
magical abilities and possibly outlive
him forever and ever we're talking this
could be a battle that is fought
throughout the centuries until Black
Adam teams up with a JSA possibly he
can't go ahead this alone you gotta have
friends it's bad for everybody you guys
know this last and we've heard it before
that being said he's going to have to
banish him at some point because the
wizard then looks for another person who
could protect magic that's when we get
Billy in the Shazam movie and also we
just have seen outlines and whatnot of
Black Adam he has to disappear at some
point between present day and the start
of time so that's gonna happen so maybe
this only occurs in the past and we say
the JSA for another outing but Vandal
Savage he's a perfect foe for someone
like Adam but what do you think who
would you like to see fight back Adam
let me know down below and make sure you
follow me on twitter at sam bash and
follow new rockstars check out my
podcast one more time with Sam basher
but most importantly make sure you check
out all the other content the new rock
stars is putting out it's up ah hello
chefs kiss in the chat for me please
I'll see you guys next time bye Mike
[Music]